good luck mister you know and I attract
the rain in our vacation yeah we need if
it doesn't rain it's not a real case
Carmichael vacation
[Music]
hello believe nation happy day for Nina
had an okay sleep I had a pretty good
sleep we are in Costa Maya today we're
gonna go on an aerial Adventure Park I'm
feeling better I'm feeling better very
exciting and it'll be the great day
everybody's here
we're the last ones here Nina are you
doing Richie you're vlogging Beauty days
all right let's get some food
where you going mister did you eat
already you done eating is it yummy
you ready to go to the aerial park all
right me too
I like it nice nice
I'm wearing my nuts I'd come to first
[Music]
look at that French toast egg potatoes
sausage other toast
in warm water all right getting ready to
get off the boat I also am testing out a
new case waterproof so I can film and
hopefully not ruin my phone I'm gonna
see how it works
[Music]
we found the Starbucks over there I
don't know that I want to try a
Starbucks on my stomach slowly getting
better but
[Music]
we're on the bus waiting to go to the
Ergo park kids took the backseat
troublemakers back there
what do you think Nina
[Music]
good luck mister going backwards
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
oh there goes Nina because Nina come on
splash splash Nina
[Music]
who's gonna get so
[Applause]
[Music]
all right we are wrapping up with the
aerial Adventure Park then we've got the
kids and see if we can hit up a local
beach before getting back to the boat
mr. find the girl lady hammock man let's
see your magic trick one two three
you brought chips amazing
[Music]
that was it mister what do you think
Nina who's gonna cover Nina Nina and I
attractive rain in our vacation yeah we
need if it doesn't rain it's not a real
car Michael vacation this rain is not
letting up so we've decided back to the
cruise eat some food
[Music]
we're back at the Starbucks big question
is Nina gonna get something or not I
really want something but not on this
stomach she's going she's going only in
Mexico
Starbucks Oh cigarette Mexican Starbucks
cigarettes and beer and Nutella
and whatever that sauce is
[Music]
how's the coffee Nina yeah that's a
happy Nina
[Music]
Wow soup
how's the soup [ __ ] a bunch of Mexican
food - hmm right - is some bread and
some apple crumble
it's my test see how the stomach is
doing this apple crumble really needs
tons of ice cream and whipped cream and
caramel sauce on top but for now we'll
just go Wayne so back in the cabin had a
pretty good late lunch I've got about an
hour so before dinner starting and I
thought this is a good time to make some
videos for you guys I'm gonna try to
make my top tens the mentor me a few
other videos while I had the luxury of
this break I'm gonna head out onto the
balcony and that's going to be the view
might be a little bit noisy from the
cruise ship and pacifiers and there's a
band playing everything but you know
what that's part of the process and
hopefully the audio quality is good
enough let's do it
and rule number five the last one before
a very special bonus clip unpacked that
Garmin key
alright filming is done super
comfortable to videos that are going to
be coming your way and we're just
shipping out we are leaving to head to
Cozumel tomorrow but first before that
we're gonna go enjoy some dinner my
appetites starting to come back and so
I'll see maybe tons of ice cream
nina know a little bit of ice cream no
[Music]
what are we going go no we're going out
to me behind my wife why I'm ready okay
let's go EJ night let's go eat dinner
guys chaos chaos with the kids man holy
cow chaos
[Applause]
[Music]
I missed the last two dining nights
because of being sick so I'm excited to
be back on with everybody dinner is here
shrimp cocktail for me salad round two
some pasta and Nina's having some
braised beef with mashed potatoes all
right dinner is done we're gonna
actually start our tradition that we
normally do go upstairs get some dessert
after our dinner
I am hoping for some cobbler with some
ice cream and caramel sighs Nina's not
just getting dessert she's getting food
vegetable noodles I like it when you
like things
[Music]
macadamia nut cookies for Nina you got a
coffee we came back to the cabin relaxed
basically just relaxed and we're
crashing so it's time to go to bed and
we're gonna wake up tomorrow and hit up
Cozumel Mexico thank you guys for
joining us on another day on our krugman
vacation I hope you're having an amazing
weekend we believe in you we hope we
continue to in yourself and we'll see
you soon